dix ans après sa condamnation à
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants à coups de pierres sur une voie
de chemin de fer à montigny-lès-metz
patrick dils obtient la révision de son
procès après avoir reconnu les faits il
s'était retraite rétracter et non
s'était rendu compte un peu plus tard de
la présence sur les lieux du drame du
tueur en série francis pour le verrier
ermite tir et kurt et et rémy
poissonnier des années qu'ils
attendaient cela des années que les
parents de patrick dils se battent pour
tenter de prouver l'innocence de leur
fils en demandant la réouverture du
dossier la commission de révision vient
de leur donner un premier espoir mais je
pense que c'est bon 12 ans
13 ans 1 mois et 15 jours du 28
septembre 86 à montigny-lès-metz le long
d'une voie ferrée
alexandre et cyril huit ans ans retrouvé
mort tué à coups de pierres sept mois
plus tard un jeune riverain de 16 ans
patrick dils et réentendu et avoue avec
précision les deux meurtres
puis il se rétracte clame son innocence
mais condamné à la perpétuité en 1989
1997 la fair deal se rebondit
francis heaulme un tristement célèbre
tueur en série reconnaît s'être trouvé
sur les lieux du crime et avoir croisé
les deux enfants même s'il nie les avoir
tués un élément nouveau qui a motivé
cette demande de révision du procès mais
un élément qui ne change rien pour la
grand mère d'un des deux enfants a
session est sûre pour elle ce que
patrick dils est le seul coupable
on était sûr que vous allez me dire ça
je suis convaincu à 100% de sa
culpabilité est tout seul et tout seul
il a fait le crime les deux crimes tout
seul
patrick dils n'est pas encore sortie ni
de prison ni d'affaires la cour de
révision va désormais instruire et
décider si oui ou non le plus jeune
condamné à la perpétuité de france devra
être rejugée un jour